[Musique]
la régie renault compte beaucoup sur son
nouveau modèle la twingo pour combattre
la morosité qui n'épargne pas non plus
le marché de l'automobile
la twingo sera commercialisé à partir de
mars 93 à un prix dit-on inférieurs à 55
milles francs
chez renault on affirme que c'est le
plus original des modèles français marie
pierre farkas et des ailes lévis ont
voulu le vérifier auprès des futurs
acheteurs
la twingo sort demain en une seule
version essence cette couleur pas
d'option et un prix sans retouches qui
frôle 55 mis fin avant même de la tester
nous l'avons livrer en pâture aux seuls
vrais verdict celui du public
premier bon point son style ne laisse
pas indifférent les badauds s'attarde
vérifie que le coffre et bien modulable
évalue sa taille 3 mètres 43 jette un
oeil étonné sur son essuie-glace tests
jusqu'à la fermeture du hayon et comment
tu sais je
on va dire une voiture branchée cette
nouvelle tir qui fait très branché et
elle ressemble à une grenouille à la des
phares qui sont très rigolo à la voiture
est original déjà par sa taille
je sais pas où ils peuvent l'être de
moteurs d'ailleurs il est peut-être à
part la couleur j'aime bien
maintenant j'aime bien couleur caramel
est bien calé ronde j'aime pas le bateau
qui a la couleur est moche et les sièges
chauffants pays moderne comme la twingo
a délibérément joué les couleurs vives
l'originalité la malice on savait très
bien chez renault qu'elle ne ferait pas
forcément l'unanimité
[Musique]